the formula 1 bath looked relaxed as he
arrived at court confidences sun is
shining ecclestone is the most powerful
man in motorsport but the charges
against him cast doubt over his future
an unhappy end to his tenure would be a
bitter pill to swallow for the man who
has made Formula One his life's work
since the 1970s ecclestone has worked at
turning what was many a sport into a
lucrative global brand since 2010
Formula One's annual turnover has grown
steadily to nearly 1.5 billion euros
most of the money comes from license
fees and TV revenues which ecclestone
has been instrumental in negotiating
before 2006 the german bank by an lb had
a stake in the business prosecutors say
ecclestone pushed for the bank to sell
its interest to a company that will keep
him in the top job he's accused of
paying 44 million u.s. dollars in bribes
to german banker gerhard gribkowsky who
was then on the bordered by an lv in
2011 gribkowsky was jailed for tax
evasion and corruption ecclestone says
he was coerced into paying the saddle
without the fact that payments were made
isn't in dispute it's about the reasons
why those payments were made of odin if
ecclestone is convicted he could face up
to 10 years in jail